how would you describe your relationship
with Daniel
um fantastic I mean I I love the man
very dearly yeah you see him as much as
I'd like to it that's the same for all
of us really but uh
I consider him a brother definitely
um
huge amounts of respect for him you say
that you actually learned more
professionally from working with him
than from any of the adults
yeah he Daniel brings a certain energy
to any room that he's in but it was
important to me looking back
um
how important his enthusiasm and his
eventual professionalism
[Music]
runs down the ranks if you will um he he
could have very much easily I think
coasted a lot of those
years and it seemed to me on set with
him that he was always up for bringing
as much as he can to the table always
being collaborative
um and I think he learned that the same
way that I did from the other chats
around us
you say that that Draco and Harry are
two sides of the same coin it could be
yeah we've had this chat but essentially
you have
you know one boy who has no parents no
money no status yeah but he has
everything he has everything that is
good with the world he has love and
compassion and friends and truth and
honesty and the other side is the
slightly darker one where very powerful
parents lots of money big house all the
toys
but also a bully and someone that can't
find a way of expressing his light
because he hasn't been shown any his
entire life and I mean these are broad
yeah yeah broad sweeps have the brush
but I think I think it's fairly true